the largest and most destructive
wildfire burning in Southern California
is threatening to spread to thousands
more homes crews battled over night to
protect picturesque coastal areas near
Santa Barbara this wildfire is now the
fifth biggest in modern California
history heavy wind is pushing the
massive Thomas fire from Ventura into
Santa Barbara County and it has already
burned 230,000 acres 790 homes and other
structures are destroyed about 5,000
people are under new evacuation orders
Jamie yuccas is in Carpinteria morning
Jamie good morning this fire that's
burned so many homes like this one has
been burning for a week it is now the
fifth largest fire in California state
history and this fire is only ten
percent contained the cost of the
firefighting effort is now thirty four
million dollars and eighteen thousand
structures are still threatened the
Thomas fire continued to burn late
Sunday crossing county lines from
Ventura into Santa Barbara County nearly
360 square miles have burned an area
bigger than New York City Sheriff Bill
Brown this fire has acted in a
predictable manner it has been very
rapidly moving and it's going to be a
multi-day event even with less extreme
wind Sunday the flames move faster than
firefighters could contain them some six
thousand firefighters are battling the
flames from the ground with the help of
29 helicopters the choppers are only
allowed to fly seven hours a day
presenting a special challenge when
fighting a fire in the winter months cAL
FIRE section chief mark Brown with the
shorter daylight period in the winter
we've actually had to launch them
earlier than we normally do in order to
maximize those hours officials are
working to keep the fire from moving
down a mountain ridge into highly
populated wealthy communities below with
celebrity homes in its path Ellen
DeGeneres tweeted our house is under
threat of being burned and from Oprah
Winfrey peace be still is my prayer
tonight for all the fires raging through
my community and beyond in all more than
30,000 people are under evacuation
warnings
Amtrak says the fires have caused it to
suspend service through this area in
addition the Santa Barbara Public
Schools say they're closed through a
winter break which means they won't
reopen until next year gale
Wow Jamie that's huge I know it's a very
frightening time for that area thank you
very much Jane Jamie